Eric Crouch way author of murdering
McKinley up top I'd like to have you do
three things explain three different
attempted assassinations
the first one is Charles Guiteau okay in
1881 what what is that have any
connection with the McKinley
assassination
well gatos shot Garfield on a train
platform in 1881 with the idea that he
was going to benefit the conservative
wing of the Republican Party katoa was
in all probability a little bit unhinged
and he had a bit of a circus of a trial
based on determining his responsibility
for the crime and which he represented
himself and then he was eventually
hanged and that influenced the McKinley
assassination in as much as it scared
the Dickens out of the prosecutors
didn't want to repeat that kind of
circus and that problem again and so
they were determined to prosecute the
assassin and do away with him fairly
quickly learning the lessons of the
Kotok ace do you haven't remember how
old Guto was I don't off the top of my
head then there's a second assassination
attempt was in 1892 that you write about
in your book now you see we had the
first one in 1881 the second one in 1882
Henry Clay Frick who was he and who was
trying to kill him Frick was a steel
executive and he was a colleague and
business partner of Andrew Carnegie and
during a strike he was trying to break a
union and an anarchist named Alexander
Berkman walked into his office and shot
and stabbed him a number of times and
what turned out to be a failed of
energetic attempt at assassination and
Berkman ultimately served 14 years in
jail
I believe for that and what what was his
relationship to a woman named Emma
Goldman who used have a relationship
with the assassin of William McKinley
Berkman was in all probability
romantically involved with Emma Goldman
and certainly he was philosophically
simpatico with Goldman they were both
anarchists and radicals actually there's
four that I said three there's four that
the next one is about 10 years later
1901 Leon and is it correct to call him
Cole gosh Cole gosh I think yeah I've
seen about four
short enunciations you have a footnote
on it what was it circumstances of his
assassination well on September 6 1901
trubbish went to a public reception that
William McKinley was holding at the
grounds of the Penn American exposition
in Buffalo New York and kobish worked
his way to the head of the line and
prepared to shake the president's hand
or rather the president prepared to
shake his hand only Chavez was holding a
revolver in his hand concealed by a
handkerchief and he shot the president
in the abdomen what are we looking at
here what we're looking at here is the
Edison company's film of the outside of
that building the temple of music at the
pan-american exposition and the crowd
waiting and hoping for McKinley to come
out he was never of course coming out to
be received I particularly like this
piece of film and I refer to it in the
beginning of the book because the
cameras are there they're at the scene
of the event you can you know that the
event is occurring behind that wall and
yet there's all this space between you
and the event and these people between
you and the event and it kind of it kind
of represents the historians problem is
that it's there but you're not quite
there and it's very difficult to tell
what's going on so you have to sift
through these recollections we had the
assassination of James Garfield 1881 the
attempted assassination of Henry Clay
Frick in 1892 the assassination of
William McKinley 1901 then about eleven
years later in 1912 John Schrank yeah
what did he tried it he shoots Theodore
Roosevelt in Milwaukee Wisconsin as
Roosevelt is on his way to give a
campaign speech this is the presidential
campaign of 1912 with Roosevelt running
as a Progressive Party candidate for
president and Schrank would say
afterwards that he didn't think anyone
should have a third term and that was
why he shot Roosevelt Roosevelt famously
went on to give the speech anyway with a
bullet in his chest
and he had been saved from death by the
fact that it passed through the folded
over pages of his speech which he had
tucked into his his breast pocket there
and the bullet had to pass through all
of that dense Roosevelt prose before it
Roosevelt's person so he was he survived
that attempt what does it say and you
know tenure increments these are just
four of other there are others but what
does it say to you when you
I you mentioned that there are others
and let me mention some of the others
because I think it's important to the
McKinley assassination to put this in a
slightly more international context in
1881 the russian tsar alexander ii is
killed by a bomb exploding under his
carriage i believe and in that year
there are meetings of some hundreds of
anarchists in paris and london who adopt
the propaganda of the deed which is a
euphemism essentially for terrorism as
their model for attacking industrial
civilization and over the next couple of
decades
there are many bombings and many
assassination attempts and many
successful assassinations and McKinley's
fits into that context as well I mean
there were bombs exploding in Paris in
London streets there were a
assassination attempts the French
president the Spanish Prime Minister the
Italian King and one of the the Habsburg
heirs were all murdered in the decade
previous preceding McKinley's death and
that was a context in which people saw
it at the time as well when did you get
interested in this and why did you get
interested in all this well I originally
got into it for um sort of academic and
scholarly reasons as time wore on I
discovered personal reasons to be
interested in it as well let me start
with this sort of the serious reasons
first I mean this assassination the
assassination of William McKinley is in
my opinion one of the most important
political events of the 20th century for
obvious reasons and for less obvious
reasons the obvious reasons are that
pretty much no assassination no
Roosevelt no Roosevelt as president
anyway no Theodore Roosevelt as
president no Franklin Roosevelt as
president in all likelihood and we you
can see where this sort of goes with
American politics
Roosevelt was far too eccentric far too
independent minded possibly far too
entertaining a person ever to be
nominated as a presidential candidate
for the Republican Party in the normal
way of thing so it took some kind of
extraordinary event to put him in the
White House that being said you know you
don't need an assassination you could be
a streetcar head William McKinley or he
ate a bad clam or something like that
but the fact that it was a political
assassination is really the more
important thing and it was this
particular kind of assassination an
anarchist assassination a radical
political assassination that gave
Roosevelt a
opportunity that he wasted no time in
seizing and in coming to the presidency
he said well now we must on the one hand
condemn anarchists and radicals as evil
they're criminals they don't understand
our American Way of life on the other
hand Roosevelt said there's something to
these complaints that the radicals have
about American society and we really
ought to regulate corporations look a
little bit more favorably on labor
unions address the circumstances of
workers in the factories regulate the
railroads that sort of thing and it was
this on the one hand on the other hand
way of speaking and of doing things that
made him such an effective president and
it was the assassination that gave him
the Avenue into that strategy so what
about the personal reason that you got
into this I discovered on doing this
that my father's grandfather slow
mechanical was one of the people whose
reference on the dedication page arrives
in New York from Austria
September 7th 1901 and so in a sense my
family story in America begins on the
day after the assassination attempt and
this is the America to which my
immigrant ancestors came and so I
developed a personal interest in there
for that reason who's the other fellow
on this list here Hans Gunther ballot
pellets that's my grandfather my
mother's father who is the most recent
male migrant in my direct ancestry who
came to this country from Germany in the
1920s when did you discover this the
that you had this relationship the the
September 7th oh yes
fairly late in the process Ellis Island
put it some records online not too long
ago and I looked him up just as a matter
of course and found that out what book
is this for you
is my second book and where do you
reside full-time I live in Davis
California doing what I teach at the
University of California at Davis and
where did you come from - Davis I had
been teaching for 3 years at Oxford in
England what kind of subjects in US
history and where did it all start in
this country for you where was I born I
I was born in Cincinnati Ohio for the
first six years of my life we moved
around a bit lived in Louisiana New York
I grew up mostly in st. Petersburg
Florida where we lived from 1976 onward
and my parents to live quite near there
till I went to college and you went to
school where at Cornell and then at
Stanford back to the assassination yeah
who was Leon Chagas well this is the the
central question of the book who was
Leon childish people thought when they
saw that this young he was about 28 some
council 825 this young man with this as
you say very difficult to pronounce name
for many Americans both then and now
people thought that this was an example
of the sort of the new immigrant coming
to our shores who posed a threat to
American societies kind of these
millions of young men who are coming to
America for strictly economic reasons
and a lot of Americans thought well
these are taking American jobs and
they're lowering American wages and they
don't want to Americanize they just want
to take our money and go home and that's
what people thought they were looking at
when they saw Leon troll gush and again
that was one of the things that gave a
sort of boost to Roosevelt's style of
politics was dealing with the immigrant
threat but on the other hand as I as I
as I spend some time developing and the
book he was not that kind of person at
all in fact he was American born he was
born in Detroit and about 1873
two parents who had come to this country
and not for those chiefly economic
reasons or not apparently for those
chiefly economic reasons they had come
fleeing oppression or the specter of
oppression in Europe and they followed
very much older pattern of migration
where the whole family would come over
with a very specific intent of intent of
becoming Americans and it was not so
much that childish was a foreigner
ultimately that that led him to an
alienation from William McKinley's
administration but the fact that he had
hopes to find a certain kind of America
and hadn't found it the circumstances of
the shooting of McKinley where was it I
know what time of day and all that I was
about 4:00 in the afternoon a little bit
after 4:00 in the afternoon in Buffalo
New York where there was a pan-american
exposition a kind of World's Fair going
on to celebrate America's connections to
the rest of the world and so like many
World's Fairs it had marvels of new
technology wonders of other lands this
sort of thing this is right on the
morrow of
because acquisition of colonial colonies
in the Philippines in the Puerto Rican
Puerto Rico so America become an
imperial power they were planning
building a canal through Central America
to connect the United States to its new
acquisitions and all of this sort of
celebration of American extension of
power was going on in Buffalo this is
some video from there as you can see
this was an electrified exposition and
the Edison Company had contributed to
the tower of light at the exposition and
there were lots of new uses of
electricity on display including there
the x-ray machine and that sort of thing
wonders of the modern world kind of
thing and the temple of music was the
largest enclosed space at the exposition
I was there that McKinley I was simply
doing what we now call the meet and
greet with the people he there was a
long line of people waiting to see the
president he went to the head of the
line started shaking hands and passing
them along how long had he been
president well he was just starting his
second term he had been elected
president 1896 and taken office in March
of 1897 then was reelected in 1900 and
that had been inaugurated for the second
time in 1901 so he's just little ways
into a second term and what did the
country think of this man well he was
tremendously popular I mean judging by
the vote anyway he was re-elected by a
comfortable majority in 1896 it had been
a bit closer a closer around the thing
between him and William Jennings Bryan
and the country was appeared to be very
strongly divided between this sort of
swath of Bryan heights in the Mountain
States and in the south and then the
sort of posts of McKinley Heights in the
Northeast and on California the Pacific
coast by 1900 it was a much much more
McKinley McKinley supportive affair and
he won by much greater margin again over
William Jennings Bryan were there Secret
Service around William McKinley when he
was shot there was Secret Service there
were a variety of New York detectives
and military men who had been detailed
to the fair and they somehow failed to
prevent the assassination now
immediately afterwards pretty much every
cop in the country began saying well had
I been there you know I would have done
this and that and they should have done
the other thing but at the time they
appeared to be doing
more or less what they thought they
should be doing lots of people thought
there was a strong chance that this was
a dangerous appearance for the president
to be making George Cortelyou who is his
personal aide thought that had a
premonition that the president shouldn't
do this particular meet and greet the
people who had planned the exposition
we're having a beer on the afternoon
just before this appearance and said
wouldn't it just be Roosevelt's luck if
the president were to be shot and there
was a general idea that again that there
were radicals out there there were
anarchists and they might take a shot at
the president at any time so how did he
do it he had a revolver in his hand and
Iver Johnson 32 and he had a white
handkerchief wrapped around it and he
simply stood in line until he got to the
president upon which he raised his hand
and shot the president twice at close
range in the abdomen and this footage
again people just waiting for him to
come out yeah people are waiting for the
president to come out and you can see
some of the the various helmets being
warned by the x-position military detail
in the front of the crowd there and
they're kind of conferring and appear to
be trying to decide what to do some of
them start scurrying a bit towards the
end of the footage and you know again
nobody knew really quite what to do at
this point did you say there was
somebody in the line that they that the
Secret Service men were suspicious of
right well afterwards I wanted Secret
Service agents gave testimony that he
had seen a swarthy man with a mustache
in the line and that he thought that
this was a suspicious person and so he
was looking at this suspicious person
instead of at cheol Ghosh and that's why
he let roguish slip by and he had sort
of looked at Chavez and say well he
looks like an ordinary young mechanic
out for the day to meet the president he
doesn't this worthy guy is somebody I
should be keeping an eye on it's where
the guy turned out to be anybody well
there's a strong chance of the swarthy
guy with a moustache could have been
James Parker who was somebody The Secret
Service man later said wasn't in the
line James Parker was a black man who
was in line behind it appears childish
who according to newspapers accounts
immediately after the shooting and up
until about the time when the president
died about a week later
tackled childish first sort of this just
for a moment this is an artist drawing
the gentlemen there were the white hand
there you know wrapped and her chief his
toga SH and the fellow right behind him
is supposed to be Parker it's supposed
to be Parker yeah this is this is a is a
representation that was done by NARS a
few years later I mean the the presence
of Parker was something that was widely
accepted in popular culture even though
it never went into the official record
it was widely reported in newspapers
Parker was interviewed and at the time
it was well known that this this this
was the Negro who saved McKinley is when
newspapers said because he had put his
arm around chocolate snack apparently
and given him a bit of a beating had
borne him to the ground and had
prevented Chagas from shooting McKinley
for a third time and if you take into
account the president survived for about
a week after being shot you know there
was a lot of there were several news
cycles in there during which people said
ah this this this african-american hero
is the man who saves McKinley and the
Secret Service later wrote him out of
the story because it made it look like
they weren't doing their job at least
that's what it appears so how many times
was he shot he shot twice where did the
bullets go well they went into the admin
one of them seems was deflected by the
president's sternum and so didn't
actually penetrate his belly the other
one went deep into the president's belly
and they never found it they tried to
get it while the president was still
alive they tried to get it after he died
and eventually they were prevailed upon
to stop looking for it and and they
never found it did apparently a great
deal of damage to the president's
pancreas and various other internal
organs which caused his body to poison
itself effectively going son didn't you
say that there was a dispute over what
happened her stomach yeah when I was
looking into the book I talked to the
Buffalo
doctor pathologist who said well you
know when I was doing my residency here
there was a story going around that his
stomach was was on display and that she
could see the bullet hole in the back of
the stomach but I never saw it he said
and then apparently nobody has either
but it's part of Buffalo lore certainly
so what happened well where was Theodore
Roosevelt at the time that President
McKinley was shot he was in in Vermont
at the Vermont Fish and Game Club
was doing what vice presidents tended to
do in those days which was not very much
that was satisfying to somebody who is
as energetic as Theodore Roosevelt and
so he received the message that the
president had been shot and he made his
way very quickly to Buffalo and then
when it appeared the president was
recovering he left again and he was on
his way up Mount to Hollis or Mount
Marcy in upstate New York when he got a
message from a park ranger that the
president was in fact dying and that he
was about to be President he should come
back to Buffalo so where did they take
the president and where did they take
Chagas the president's body was laid out
in Buffalo first it was eventually put
on a plaque sit sorry she's not one of
did you get that week when he was still
alive right yes of course well um he had
been taken to the he was first he was
worked on at or near the exposition by
some doctors who were who present who
tried to you know who got the the one
bullet and set it aside and then who
tried to find the other bullet and then
he was put up at the exposition one of
the exposition managers housed a man
called John Milburn in Buffalo where he
was sort of recuperating and under the
attention of several physicians for this
week where there excuse me were there
people working on him when he was alive
that ended up being in the picture later
any of those doctors that were involved
in any kind of an investigation uh not
that not that I know that there is a
sort of within the community of Medicine
there's a sort of controversy as whether
all had been done that could be done to
save McKinley and I think it's basically
resolved that given the state of
Medicine at the time they had done about
what they could do it was why did he end
up dying out well ultimately I mean
ultimately he died because he this
sepsis in the in the abdomen it appears
but I mean the proximate cause was the
gunshot he wouldn't have died otherwise
how old was he uh he was at that time
what's he been born in 1843 so he was 58
and where was his wife in this whole
thing and she was she was by the
president's eye by this time yeah and
Chagas what they do with him Chagas well
first they took him away to the the
Buffalo Police Headquarters
for interrogation and then the his his
movements are not entirely clear during
this time there's some the did Buffalo
DA Thomas penny later said you know I'm
not gonna release any records more than
I have to I don't want to talk about
this more than necessary I don't think
that's any constructive purpose served
by keeping this before the public you
know we got him he's the guy who did it
he says he did it let's not talk about
the details now what he was trying to
conceal is you know not clear as well as
it's always the case when officials are
trying to conceal things but they had
him in in their custody for a while then
he was taken to trial in a New York
Court and he was tried over a very risk
trial of a couple days and then he was
sentenced to electrocution where he was
in an Auburn state prison he was
electrocuted a little over a month after
that we have some more video this is the
Auburn state prison have you seen this
before I have you know we got this
thanks to your recommendation in the
book from the library cars this is a
reenactment yeah again this is the
Edison Company and it's the same thing
as the footage that we saw at the
exposition the as incoming couldn't
really get to the event so they were
filming outside the prison as they said
the time of the execution and then they
appended this this reenactment of the
execution here is fairly detailed and
somewhat grim in fact reenactments of
the execution what was his what was this
the first electrocution
oh no no no they've been actually
killing people since 1889 90 they'd in
in New York State
first electrocution was a medical
William Kemmler also in Auburn prison
now what are we seeing here one that
they and what's the purpose is showing
that there they hit him once and they
hit him again the again that you you
know this is it this is the Edison
company's impression of what might have
happened and if they hit him once and
they hit him again they may be trying to
reproduce the the controversial Kemmler
execution first time they did it that
recruited somebody didn't go very very
well they either they elected they
electrified him for the wrong amount of
time or something else something else
went wrong
with the wrong amount of current and you
know he didn't die right away and they
had to electrify him again to do it and
here you see the doctors apparently
checking to make sure that his dead from
the moment he shot McKinley until till
he was killed himself how many days I
don't know how many day just late
October when you learn but he's a couple
it's some weeks six weeks or something
like that a little over that yeah and
what kind of a story was at the time in
the press did you look at the old
newspapers oh yeah I mean you know once
once he'd been sentenced to death and it
was simply awaiting death it was a sort
of a lull in the coverage of the case
and then it came out again when he was
electrocuted
partly because apparently the prison
warden made an extraordinary decision on
how to dispose of the body which they
they designed a special coffin and a
special grave into which they were going
to put sulfuric acid to dissolve the
body more quickly rather than the usual
quick climb and the prison warden you
know was trying to keep anyone from
taking away bits of the body for medical
analysis again it's probably likely he'd
wanted to make sure that there wasn't
extended discussion of the case that it
was going to be open-and-shut and so
they were effectively destroying
whatever remains there were Joker she's
buried somewhere well it would have been
a grave within the grounds of one of our
burn prison and the body isn't there
anymore and William McKinley was what
kind of a funeral did he have well you
know he only had an elaborate state
funeral you seem to have some footage of
it there as he was he was taken to Lyon
State in in Washington and then to his
hometown of Canton Ohio
it started in Buffalo and where I have
some video also in the capital and on
the Canton what impact did this have on
the country and the change to Roosevelt
well it it provided as as these kinds of
elaborate ceremonies can a sense of the
orderly transition of power and that you
know they were grieving for this this
man who as I said before was
tremendously popular in 1901 and he was
laid away in Canton where he is still
regarded as as a rather a local hero
what was your reaction to having
Theodore Roosevelt as the president well
that's pensive you asked and
McKinley's friends were many of them
very nervous as I said before Roosevelt
was a very independent-minded man's the
pomp you thought of him as being
eccentric he was somebody who took
radicalism much more seriously than
other Republicans tended to do I mean
McKinley's when McKinley's friends and
colleagues was the industrialist and
campaign manager and later senators Mark
Hannah who is responsible for the the
well-known possibly apocryphal quotation
now look at that damn cowboy his
President of the United States referring
to to Theodore Roosevelt who Hannah
regard as a loose cannon and so when
Roosevelt came to the presidency his
again a willingness to adopt us on the
one hand on the other hand kind of
rhetoric on the one hand we must
criminalize anarchism and wage war on it
as if it were international piracy on
the other hand we must do some things to
eliminate the causes of radicalism was
an attempt to navigate this distrusted
him among Republican leaders and the
popular reception that something might
be done now how how many books have been
written about the McKinley assassination
many I there were a couple just in the
last year or so since it was the
centennial in 1901 and there had been
one or two in the earlier part of the
century it had entered the kind of the
literature of assassinations you know as
you start up by mentioning Guto and and
there are there's a small literature on
presidential assassinations and most of
that literature centers on whether the
assassin was sane or not and therefore
you know why people would want to shoot
the president
it's a question that obviously was the
central question following the McKinley
assassination and even following child
wishes execution there was a little bit
of a hue and cry within the
psychological community as to whether
they might have done a little bit more
to determine his state of mental health
and it was that investigation at
post-mortem investigations at rubbishes
insanity that provided the the bulk of
the the primary source material for my
book the the notes that the
psychologists look when they're
interviewing his family and his friends
and this sort of thing and that hadn't
been looked at in any great detail
before to explain how that whole
investigation started well in about
November of 1901 not too
after the assassination a Boston doctor
named Walter Channing who had in his
employ another doctor named Lloyd Vernon
Briggs decided to undertake a private
investigation of child washes family
history with an eye on to determining
whether he had been mad or not and
whether therefore justice had been
served in executing him rather than
committing him and Channing had followed
these kinds of crimes over the decades
had weighed in on the gita' case on the
side of the assassin being insane so he
was he took an interest in this
particular problem of criminal as our
versus insane assassins and Briggs was a
younger man who chaning employed simply
to go do the footwork essentially for
the investigation and Briggs therefore
went to Auburn went to Buffalo went to
Detroit went to Cleveland where Joe Bush
his family lived and interviewed he
ultimately said some dozens of people to
find out what kind of man show gosh I
had been and that's how we know that's
how I know that trollers was not what he
appeared to be because Briggs got the
straight story again what did he appear
to be well again people looked at him
and they they saw this name that had a
lot of consonants in it and they they
saw this young man the sort of
disaffected worker who had been out of
work for a few years and they thought
well this is this is a classic case of
the new immigrant this people would say
this sort of this problem that is
plaguing America these some 18 millions
of new immigrants between 1890 and 1914
came to the United States the vast
majority of them were young men who were
simply seeking employ and had no
interest in staying and becoming
American citizens and so people fixated
on childish as being foreign and being a
threat to American institutions and in
fact that is trial the Buffalo District
Attorney said here is this
representative of this class who have
come to our shores and have no regard
for our institutions which was somewhat
ironic since the Buffalo District
Attorney was in fact an immigrant
although chill ghost was not Henny Penny
yeah Thomas penny he came from he came
from Britain and I want to show this
picture again so and and we can spell
the name for those have never seen it
before it's there on the in the cut line
but Yogesh c zo l g o s z
you know his father again came from
where came from what was then part of
Prussia a town called Posen it appears
and Chagas some people say maybe
Hungarian in its ethnic origins but they
spoke polish and were part of a Polish
community by the time they came over and
were in the United States he was born
where Chagas Chagas leon chavez was born
in detroit how many kids in the family
eight or nine it appears it's again
that's not quite clear but somewhere in
that range and one of the brothers
played a part in the investigation of
Channing and Briggs
well they interviewed several of his
brothers Leon's brother waldecker valdek
I'm not really sure how you approach
that either frankly was a major source
for Lloyd Vernon Briggs because he was
among the siblings the closest to Leon
had worked at the same wire factory as
Leon and had gone through a number of
the same sort of political awakenings as
Leon had done and so he testified as to
those two Briggs in the course of the
investigation what kind of a life had
Leon had well it was not it was not
unusual he had he'd grown up in this
family that that came to Michigan there
are an awful lot of poles and other
Asian Europeans who came to Michigan and
they moved sort of from city to
countryside and back I mean it appears
their goal was to buy a farm and so they
would live in a city and they would work
and save up their money as best they
could until they could afford to buy
some land now in those days it was very
hard to earn a living wage and put by
money if you were doing essentially
unskilled to what the census then called
least skilled labor which was what Paul
shoulders was doing and so cyclical
unemployment was very common if you were
in Paul Shull bushes line of work which
related to the timber industry quite
often you might be unemployed maybe
three months of the year for seasonal
reasons here's the day that's Paul
childish there that's right
that's a photograph taken shortly after
the assassination your children would
probably have to work in order to
augment the family's income if you had
any
- they save up money and so Leon and the
other trolls children did work they
worked in Leon worked in a glassblowing
Factory after going to public school
later on he worked in a steel wife wire
factory he appears to have been a fairly
skilled worker doing what they Foreman
called fancy wire work in the factory so
he might have been earning a slightly
better wage and some of his brothers
when did Leon get involved in politics
of any kind I came on the and the wake
of the 1893 panic and depression which
is a really epical event in American
history is this panic which came on the
heels of a big boom which was driven in
turn by the the desire to annex and
consolidate our hold on the western
states was an arm's Norma's amount of
railway construction of telegraph wire
laying a barbed wire stringing all of
which drove the steel industry and a big
boom the boom went bust beginning in the
early 1890s and in 1893 there was this
terrible panic that was exacerbated by
some Muslims not very wisely conceived
laws that the federal government had
adopted in the early 1890s and all the
gold went leaching out of the United
States Treasury and people began
withdrawing their deposits from American
banks and in response to this you know
credit obviously became very hard to get
as it does in recessions and people who
employ other people began laying them
off which was what happened to Leon and
millions of other Americans at that time
and so he was put out of work then and
it was then that he and his brother of
all deck began looking into you know why
America wasn't doing for them what they
believed it was supposed to do and they
they read around a lot and first they
began to question on Catholicism and
then later on they they began to
question in capitalism but only in a
very mild sort of way I mean Leon's
favorite book was a very well known very
well selling novel by Edward Bellamy
called Looking Backward which was this
the most tepid form of socialism you
could possibly imagine and it
hypothesized that although we now in
Bellamy was referencing 1887 a little
bit before that we now live in this kind
of grim industrial world where people
can't find well-paying work or constant
work sometime in the future in value put
that data as the year 2000 we would live
in
society that had peacefully evolved into
one that was much better managed in
which machines did most of the dirty
work and people were free to enjoy their
leisure this was a tremendously popular
book and drove a political movement of
its own there were Bellamy clubs and
that sort of thing and Leon was it as a
devotee of that political philosophy for
most of the 1890s as far as we can tell
there's a group of pictures here I have
caricatures of Emma Goldman and she was
Emma Goldman was an anarchist who also
an immigrant had come to this country in
the in the 1880s and the event that
provided her political awakening was the
1886 Haymarket bombing in Chicago for
which for anarchists were hanged
it was later concluded pretty-pretty
undoubted pretty doubtlessly without
much evidence and that fired her sense
of injustice so she became an anarchist
at that time and she was as we've
already said associated with Berkman the
would-be assassin of Henry Clay Frick
and she was this sort of fire-eating
orator and rhetorician who went around
the country giving these to be speeches
about how you know you should resist
attorney
what's an anarchist what's an anarchist
well this is a fair question because the
the anarchist at that time would not
have agreed what an anarchist was and
there's a kind of irony involved in the
notion of anarchist societies at all but
an anarchist is somebody an anarchist in
the 1890s was somebody who believed that
there should be no government that any
considerable accumulation of property
was a form of theft that got laws
existed to therefore to reinforce theft
and that government was therefore
complicit in this form of oppression and
they looked forward to as communists
would have said withering away of this
state and the coming of a socialist
utopia they disagreed over how that was
going to happen and whether was going to
happen violently if it was going to
happen violently should they try to
precipitate the violence or says that
they simply armed themselves in
anticipation of the state trying to
stamp them out or should they just wait
and hope and there was there were all
stripes of anarchists
in America at that time how did it at
goldman get her start
well she underwent this sort of almost
religious awakening in the wake of the
Haymarket from where where was she based
and um I don't actually know she
traveled around so much I don't know
actually know where she was but what she
thought of it did the public know about
her oh she was she was widely known as
an amber anarchist figure and indeed
suspicion lit on her immediately after
the assassination in 1901 because she
was she had been in Cleveland which was
Leon's hometown not too much before the
assassination and it was said that
Childish had attended this speech and it
does appear that jugglers did try to
seek her out and meet her because he was
inspired by her in some way and you know
there was little brief face-to-face
meeting at a railway platform in Chicago
after one of her speeches in which she
basically told him to go away
and had some of her friends tell him to
go away because they thought that
anybody who was so eager to meet Emma
Goldman to find out about secret Atticus
sells must be a police spy and so they
tried with might and main to get rid of
him in fact they published in one of
their newsletters and noticed that the
warning this is a spy don't go near him
and so they the anarchists were very
keen to distance themselves from Lee and
Cholas before the assassination
afterwards Emma Goldman kind of went
soft on him and started running about it
was poorly on and said you know this
this man you know even though he may
have been deluded was obviously
operating in the spirit of true
anarchism you go back to when we started
the program we're talking about the four
assassinations that he had toe the next
one that would have been the Haymarket I
mean the frick frick attempted
assassination then the McKinley
assassination then John Schrank who shot
Theodore Roosevelt what were what what
did the public think about is this a
form of terrorism first of all and and
what was it how much comment was her
through those twenty thirty years in the
public print well there's a tremendous
amount of comment and it was regarded as
form of terrorism that was a word that
they used quite widely in assessing
chocolate after the fact one of the
physicians said you know if we're going
to call this man mad we had to call all
anarchists matter of fact we have to
call all terrorists mad
and the this particular physician so you
know and I and you can see that point
that what they want and how they think
they're going to get it it's mad on the
other hand you know it's mad in a
political sense it's not mad in a
clinical sense and that was the
distinction they felt themselves forced
to draw for legal reasons obviously by
the way what's your own conclusion after
you've read all about this was childish
a madman I was he insane why I don't
think I don't think there's any evidence
that he was insane in in the in the in
the sense that he should have been
committed rather than executed and but
that's a very narrow legal sense I mean
in my mind anyone who shoots anybody in
cold blood is it to some degree Matt
obviously that doesn't let them off the
hook
but between that narrow legal sense of
being responsible for your actions and
the much larger sense of having an off
kilter view of society there's a lot of
shades of grey I mean I try to paint a
picture of that world as trubbish lived
in it and to give a sense of how he
could have come to this pass and
pointing out that you know these were
not uncommon experiences but alone among
these people these many many millions of
Americans who have these experiences
he's the one who decided to shoot the
president on account of them gita' was
was executed by our government what
happened to Alexander Berkman Berkman
served 14 years in prison I think of a
longer sentence you know and he tried to
kill Frick and then what happened to
John Schrank Schrank was committed
because they said he was insane because
he said a vision of William McKinley had
come to him and told him that Roosevelt
was his true murderer and that he should
be avenged and so shrank got off being
he had committed the the crime in a
state that didn't have capital
punishment which Roosevelt thought was a
sign of his sanity that he had tracked
Roosevelt through several other states
where Roosevelt said he was surely would
have been lynched he tried to shoot me
in Tennessee but he was he was committed
and do I remember you saying he lived
about into the 40s sometimes I may have
said that yes he did live he did live
into Franklin Roosevelt's presidency
what was TRS reaction where there are
different reactions to the assassination
of McKinley and his attempted assassin
assassination in 1912 yeah this is a
this is in my mind
critical difference between a two
assassination attempts the first one the
I mean the first successful
assassination of McKinley was as I say
politically very useful to Roosevelt it
let him say these people who would shoot
at our leaders are criminals we must
fight a war against them oh and by the
way that includes anyone who would give
them aid and comfort which means
basically the entire Democratic Party
and William Randolph Hearst in his
newspaper chain which gave Roosevelt a
nice stick with which to beat his
political opponents and then I said on
the other hand you know he wanted to
address what he believed with the causes
of the misery in which stalkers should
come up and and had become alienated
from society and so there was an
extremely useful political tool for
someone who was you know a kind of a
genius of creating useful political
tools Theodore Roosevelt the
assassination attempt on him in 1912 was
not nearly so useful this man first of
all said he wanted to prevent Roosevelt
having a third term which painted
Roosevelt in a rather unflattering light
as an excessively ambitious man which
was one of his vulnerabilities in in the
public mind anyway and second of all he
was probably somewhat mad or appeared to
be somewhat mad and so it was as if he
had been struck by accident by some
force of nature it didn't give him a
sort of political handle that he could
really pull on he tried I mean his
appearing at that speech with the bullet
in his chest was it was a tremendous
gesture of political ambition and you
know I excerpt quite a bit of that
speech in the book to give you a sense
of what Roosevelt is saying you know
here I have been shot and I appear
before you with this bullet in my chest
and I'm doing this because I truly
believe in the progressive cause and if
I were to die it would be worth dying I
have had an a one time in life and I'm
having one now he said and even this to
him was an opportunity to be seen for
the moment let's stop in the 1912 1912
he was running for the third time bull
moose party well he it was it wouldn't
wasn't going technically going to be a
third term it would have appeared to be
a third term because he had served
almost all of McKinley's first term but
he had only been elected once in 1904 in
his own right and then he had decided in
1908
not to run again partly amid you know
sort of press accusations that this
would be third term ISM and that was you
know unbecoming ambition Woodrow Wilson
wins that presidency but he but but
Theodore Roosevelt gets a lot more votes
than the president William Howard Taft
that's right yeah Taft came third place
it was um it was actually a four-way
election in many people's minds because
there was also the socialist candidate
Eugene Debs who had been the head of the
American railway Union and so there was
Debbie and Wilson and Roosevelt and
between the three of them they were
vying for the anti Taft vote which was
actually very large if you take the
obviously the three of them together and
then there was Taft who was plugging
away saying look none of these radical
changes that these men are proposing are
really necessary we ought to hew to a
much more conservative line do you
remember the date Theodore Roosevelt was
shot I told it was it was very close to
the election so it had been in about
October of 1912 oh yeah the city and the
exact circumstances Milwaukee Wisconsin
and he was um he was getting out of
getting into a car at his hotel on his
way to the auditorium where he's going
to give a speech and he had appears to
have gotten into his car and then in the
characteristic Roosevelt gesture decided
to bounce up again and wave to the crowd
and he was shot while he was waving so
you know the wedding Roosevelt made a
joke about that but I can't read what
the joke was he said it was it was not a
large enough caliber to kill a bull
moose ultimately was it was the gist of
the joke how many times was he shot I
believe was just the once and how did he
know that he wasn't hurt I mean and
where did the bullet go right well the
bullet went through his is his speech as
I say which was in his breast pocket and
then it hit him in the fleshy part of
the chest it appears and he kind of
looked down himself and he didn't think
that there was any arterial blood coming
on he coughs which he said you know he
remembered from being a soldier that was
one way to tell if there was internal
bleeding and he didn't cough up in blood
and so he said to himself well I can go
on and do this now that this was a
considerable risk I mean whatever
precautions he took to go walking around
a bullet in your chest is never a good
idea but he was thought it was worth the
risk to achieve this political end of
giving this important speech and when he
gave his speech how long was it and how
much of this did he show the audience
the fact that he had been shot
well he he stood before the audience and
he pulled out the the text of the speech
so that people could see that the bullet
had passed through the speech and then
when he opened his jacket they could see
that there was blood on his shirt and so
this was a very it appears it was
somewhat surprising to Roosevelt it
appears he did not know how much blood
there was or that the speech had been
perforated at that point but in any case
it was a very dramatic gesture and as I
say it gave Roosevelt this this sort of
spur to deliver this fairly long almost
an hour speech in which he sort of
explained why he was running as a
progressive and why he was you know
repudiating the Republican Party and why
he was challenging Debs and Wilson as
demagogues of the left and why he was
the sensible centrist candidate and as I
say why he was having such a good time
doing it and what happened to him after
the speech then he went to the hospital
and then he was given some medical
attention and turned out it hadn't been
quite so bad and he was laid up it
wasn't able much to campaign and there
was some gentlemanly humming and hawing
by the other candidates saying they
wouldn't speak but there was there was
really not much result after that as I
say it was fairly close to the election
and he was fairly discouraged ultimately
having lost the election even though he
knew there's probably going to do that
but that was that was just about the end
of his political career really that
election if I remember I I don't know
there's electoral votes are popular was
he got something like 27% of the vote he
very well in the popular vote most ever
of a third party candidate possibly
until Ross Perot I'm not sure about that
but yes go back to the the thing that
got you the most intrigued they knew
information that you got in all this the
chatting the water chanting Boston
versus the the Briggs what was his
Vernon's rolling Briggs where did you
get the Briggs material um it's it's
it's it's no secret briggs published a
book called the manner of man that kills
in 1921 drawing off of his notes and one
of his case studies was childish but his
actual notes are lodged with Channing's
papers in the Massachusetts Historical
Society his actual notes are a much rarh
and fresher than what's in the book and
I think you know as legal documentation
several months after the fact but as as
far as evidence of what briggs saw and
heard while he was investigating chavez
family i think it's pretty good because
he took these notes as he went along he
typed them up but he mailed them to
chaning by registered mail and so
they're sort of a fresh depiction of
what he found while he went on that trip
from Auburn to Buffalo and into Detroit
and Cleveland to meet trubbish his
family and acquaintances and talk to
them about what kind of man Chavez had
been and I think it must therefore be a
pretty good picture of what kind of man
chocolate was if there had been a sort
of conspiracy of Lies it would have
involved some dozens of people and
that's just seems very unlikely Channing
and Briggs and I'll come back to the
kind of a Kenny and Briggs had a
falling-out they did have a falling-out
who were they again who was Walter
Channing
Walter Channing was as I think
Bostonians would say of the Boston
Channing's he was of a very eminent
Boston family he was a descendant of
William Ellery Channing at the Unitarian
he was related to various other civic
figures and he had been and heavily
involved in the civic life of the city
of Boston by virtue of his family name
he was in his 50s fifty-three I believe
at that in 1901 Briggs was a younger man
although not as young as people said he
was 38 in 1901 but people always talked
about him as being boyish and referred
to him as a young man this is partly
because he had had to work to support
his family too and had only been able to
enter medical school and achieve his MD
in 1899 and so he was sort of fresh out
of medical school as he was working with
Channing
on this case and he had Channing had
been away from his private sanitarium
and left Briggs in charge and Briggs had
kind of changed the regime at the
sanitarium and implemented a lot of his
new what he would have called
progressive ideas for how to treat
people and get them more quickly out
onto on the street and back as this I
believed really in curing the insane or
the nervous which Channing was more
skeptical about and preferred more to
sort of give them comfort and they
represented sort of a more progressive
and a more conservative point of view
with respect to that after all their
study what were the conclusions they
both concluded that childish was insane
although for different reasons
Channing basically said what I've just
said to you is I can't imagine that any
sane person would do this which doesn't
sound like a medical opinion but in 1901
a I suppose it could be 1902 it was a
time that he gave that talk Briggs
gave a sort of theory in line with a lot
of the the newer psychology of the day
having to do with a developmental theory
about how Joel Ghosh had had a deformed
or perverse secondary ego and therefore
he was unable to have empathy for other
people and this was this was the source
of his dementia and ultimately insanity
what they do with the report um they
each publish their separate versions of
the report and then as you say they went
their separate ways
what was the falling-out about well the
the real cause of the falling-out is
somewhat mysterious as I say they had
very different views of how to treat
their patients and they were probably
going to separate ways anyway it became
a political set too between the two of
them because Briggs was lobbying for and
ultimately was successful in seeing
through the Massachusetts state's
legislature a number of laws to regulate
the treatment of the insane and in fact
one of the later laws actually is
usually referred to by his name the
Briggs law for dealing with the criminal
or the possibly criminally insane and so
he was pushing to get through these laws
and they would have done chaning out of
his living and that's what Briggs would
have said now Channing said that the
falling out was because Briggs was a man
of bad character and what he meant by
that apparently was that Briggs had had
extramarital affair rather had had
premarital affairs with a variety of
women including some of the patients at
the asylum and Briggs
I don't feel too bad about saying this
because brings himself published this in
his own memoir of the of the set to that
they had but it was it was a personal
attack that Channing had leveled against
Briggs
how long did Briggs try to investigate
the family and the connections and there
in his pursuit of this conclusion it was
a very intense trip he was on the road
for some weeks and then he came back and
wrote it up well where did he get the
best material on on Leon Yogesh I mean
to my mind the best material comes from
his visit to Cleveland where he
met trubbish his whole family and a lot
of the people who knew him when he was
young and the people that bored people
who had the boarding house where he
sometimes stayed when he visited upstate
New York he was seen people who had only
known Chavez for a very short time and
that at the end of his life and in
Detroit he only saw people who don't I
was very young if at all so the
Cleveland was the bulk of the good
material
Cleveland was where rubbish had spent
most of his adult life where he had
worked when he worked where he had been
put out of work when he worked and so
that was where most of the material was
to be fed how did he get the family I
mean you you paint a picture of you know
and you can see it in modern-day here
they come again it's another reporter
it's and somebody else wanting
information and they don't want to talk
to people how did he get through that
that barrier in fact it appears that he
almost missed them he lit upon them as
they were moving and I'm not sure he
would have known where they were going
to in Cleveland yeah
and who was he approaching well he was
trying to talk to Paul Chavez the father
and the various siblings who were in the
home at the time which wasn't all of
them but there was a number of them in
and near that Paul's home at that time
and you know he hired an interpreter to
speak into numbers of the family who
didn't speak English or didn't speak it
very well and he spoke to toggle she's
younger sister Victoria he did did speak
English and and valdek spoke English
also but I think I think he just you
know he present by presenting himself as
a doctor rather than as a reporter as
somebody who was a man of science he was
able to kind of present himself more
sympathetically then then simply a
reporter who was interested in getting
the story especially because there had
been so many false and sensationalistic
accounts in the newspapers between the
assassination and this time here was
somebody who's saying look I'm going to
give this the professional imprimatur of
a science and it'll be published in a
journal one that sort of thing and
Briggs and Channing published their
documentation what year Channy published
a paper in nineteen two and Briggs
published his own in a book much later
in 1921 they gave they gave public
papers in 1902 very shortly after brings
his trip go back to the trial which
happened right after the September
assassination right
what did Chagas say at the time in the
trial in the trial he didn't he didn't
say but I think one sentence which was
he tried to plead guilty and the judge
wouldn't admit the plea apparently
because he couldn't have a guilty plea
and what was a potentially a capital
case and that was all he ever said at
the trial he said a few other things at
this sentencing where he said he wanted
to make sure that they knew that he had
acted alone and that there was nobody
else in it with him
and did the insanity issue come up in
the trial well this is very interesting
to me
Thomas Penney we've already talked about
the Buffalo DA impaneled three doctors
to determine trubbish --is sanity for
the prosecution and then in what was a
very I think potentially a very shrewd
move also got a couple of other doctors
to act as it were for troll gush to
determine whether or not he was sane and
both sets of doctors concluded that
childish was sane and therefore
responsible for what he had done so
chose so penny apparently decided at
that point not to bring it up at all at
the trial when cho Ghosh's attorneys who
had been appointed had been selected by
the Erie Bar Association and were
appointed to take his case he didn't
appear to want them because anarchists
don't believe in the law was the
argument when childish his attorney is
particularly Loren Lewis got up to speak
on his behalf they kind of introduced
the concept of insanity as the only way
that the jury could find that toga
should not be found guilty and put to
death and they made a sort of purely
rhetorical plea for atrocious insanity
without really presenting any evidence
at all and in fact it's a very it's a
very shrewd tactic of courtroom rhetoric
that he's essentially pleading for the
jury to kind of do what the law wouldn't
have allowed them to do which is fine
I've been saying without much of a case
there but Lewis was saying you know
wouldn't it be much nicer if we were to
find this man wasn't saying it would has
been as if the President had been killed
in a railway accident we should regret
it very much but it would lift a great
cloud off the hearts of the world and of
our people if it were that kind of
accident rather than if it turned out to
be the product of of an anarchist plot
in the very first page and the press
she write among the presidential
assassins William McKinley's had the
most dangerously political motive
Abraham Lincoln's murder was waging the
civil war by other means James
Garfield's assassin claimed divine
inspiration
whatever motives may have been spurred
john f kennedy's killer remained murky
for assassinations in our 43
presidencies
any thread there on those four you know
there have been attempts to connect them
i don't know that i find any of them
persuasive the sort of the high-water
mark of attempts to categorize
presidential assassins was in the 1950s
which was also the high-water mark of
social science and of psychology
generally i think in that kind of
discussion and it you know the saying
that these were loners saying that these
were men who were alienated from their
families doesn't say a whole lot
there are awful lot of people like that
who never take a shot at the president
and so i i'm not sure that i believe
that here's the cover of the book and on
the cover three men there on the left
theodore roosevelt in the middle William
McKinley and Leon Childress on the right
who killed William McKinley in 1901 Eric
Rush way is our guest thank you very
much for joining us thank you